Wow, welcome.
Welcome to the show, everybody.
The last 24 hours in American politics are
the craziest 24 hours I've ever been involved
with from the standpoint of of covering them.
And we had, I think, six hours of live streams
yesterday in addition to the broadcast show
and the bonus show and almost an impossibility
to even keep up with what is going on.
So today's show is going to be very different
than any show we've done.
We are in a sense, we are winging it.
And what I mean by that is I have about 13
or 14 different stories that I would like
to talk about today.
And we may get to all of them and we may not.
In other words, I'm starting today not with
every minute planned as we normally have,
but with an idea of the things we should discuss
and we'll just jump into them.
And I hope I know a lot of you have been emailing
me saying I can't keep up.
Well, we we haven't been able to keep up either.
So let's try to do justice to the last 24
hours because the historical significance
really cannot be overstated.
Let's start with what happened yesterday.
Yesterday, January 6th was meant to be the
day during which there would be a merely ceremonial
counting of the electoral votes which were
cast on December 14th in the November election.
Joe Biden won the popular vote in the 50 U.S.
states, winning some, losing some, getting
enough electoral votes to become president.
On December 14th, the electors in all 50 states
certified their states election.
And on January 6th, those ballots already
having been cast on December 14th, a joint
session of the House and Senate led by Vice
President Mike Pence as president of the Senate,
was to simply count those votes.
Now, we knew there would be some chaos because
for two months, Donald Trump has been insisting
without evidence that he actually won, that
it was rigged, that he wants this state to
be overturned, that he wants that state to
be overturned, that there were massive dumps
of ballots, that Mike Pence needs to do the
right thing.
And that something.
And it wasn't just Trump, but many of his
most sycophantic supporters who were hoping,
planning, believing that something would happen
yesterday that would prevent Joe Biden from
being determined in that joint session by
Mike Pence, the winner of the 2020 election.
Now, I'll skip to the end.
It happened it was delayed by a few hours,
but it happened and we will get to that.
But what we imagine would simply be some debate.
We knew there would be senators and members
of the House on the Republican side standing
up and objecting to the counting of ballots
from certain states, Arizona, for example,
Pennsylvania and others.
We knew that would happen.
We expected there would be a couple of hours
of debate for each of those objections, but
that ultimately Republicans didn't have the
vote to hold up even a single state's votes
from being counted and that it might be 10
p.m.
It might be one a.m., it might be 3:00 a.m.
it might be this morning or later today.
Eventually, they would run out of objections,
they would run out of votes, and that would
be it.
But something else happened.
Something else happened, which is that in
the morning, Donald Trump incited an insurrectionist
mob to march down Pennsylvania Avenue to the
Capitol building and wreak havoc, break down
doors and destroy windows, commit property
crimes, fight with police, put some police
actually injured.
And this was fomented directly by Donald Trump.
And this is not to say that many of these
folks didn't have this idea going into yesterday
already.
But I am going to show you how Donald Trump
did this.
Donald Trump literally told them what to do
and later said, oh, please be peaceful, but
we will get to that.
Here is Donald Trump at this wacky event.
I don't know what they were calling it.
It was a steal the election rally, essentially.
Here is Trump again saying, Mike Pence, you'd
better do the right thing.
The left knows exactly what they're doing.
They're ruthless.
And it's time that somebody did something
about it.
And Mike Pence, I hope you're going to stand
up for the good of our Constitution and for
the good of our country.
And if you're not, I'm going to be very disappointed
in you.
I will tell you right now, I'm not hearing
good stories.
Ultimately, Donald Trump ended up denouncing
his own vice president, Mike Pence.
And we will get to that later.
Donald Trump continuing to fire up the crowd
by saying the caravans are forming.
Remember those caravans that up until the
day before the twenty eighteen midterms were
every day in right wing media.
The caravans of dangerous Hispanic immigrants
are coming.
Twenty eighteen midterms happened.
We don't hear about the caravans ever again
until yesterday.
Here is Trump ginning up more.
By saying the caravans are forming because
they know Biden will let them in.
But now the caravans they think Biden's getting
in, the caravans are forming again.
They want to come in again and rip off our
country.
Can't let it happen.
And then here is Donald Trump just literally
telling them what to do, saying we're going
to march up Pennsylvania Avenue, we're going
to go to the Capitol.
He said he told them what to do and they did
it.
Take a look.
We're going to walk down Pennsylvania Avenue.
I love Pennsylvania Avenue and we're going
to the Capitol and we're going to try and
give the Democrats a hopeless.
They're never voting for anything, not even
one vote.
But we're going to try and give our Republicans
the weak ones because the strong ones don't
need any of our help.
We're going to try and give them the kind
of pride and boldness that they need to take
back our country.
So let's walk down Pennsylvania Avenue.
I want to thank you all.
God bless you and God bless America.
Thank you all for being here.
This is incredible.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
And that is exactly that is exactly what they
did while we were covering what I thought
would just be really boring debate for hour
after hour about Republican objections to
the counting of ballots from certain states.
We saw live and we saw what we had over one
point one million different people watch at
least some piece of our live stream.
Yesterday, we all saw with with horror, most
of us, as the angry mob of Trump became angrier
and angrier, fighting with police, eventually
overwhelming law enforcement.
And there are many questions about how that
happened, where where was law enforcement?
And there was everything from speculation
to conspiracy theories to mere belief of incompetence.
And at some point we will sort that out.
Overwhelming law enforcement breaking into
the Capitol, leading to Mike Pence being taken
out of their base by a Secret Service, leading
to House and Senate leadership being taken
sort of in protective custody or, you know,
by security to safe, safe locations.
An evacuation of the House and Senate chambers,
protestors and mobsters and rioters, I don't
even know what to call them, broke into Nancy
Pelosi's office.
And they did they did exactly what would be
on the logical end of two months of firing
people up with lies, culminating with Trump
saying at twelve thirty pm, half an hour before
this all started, we're going to march over
down Pennsylvania Avenue to the Capitol eventually
after things got completely out of control.
And I know I'm not going to get every detail
right or I'm not going to get every detail
into the story.
Discussions about do we deploy.
The National Guard reports that Trump resisted,
but ultimately, Mike Pence made the decision
to deploy the National Guard.
Trump seemingly not wanting to deploy the
National Guard against his own supporters.
And eventually, Donald Trump uploaded a video
saying to people, it's time to go home.
He says, you're great people.
We love you.
It was stolen.
It was a landslide.
Then we actually won.
But it's time to go home.
And that video was ultimately locked by Twitter,
later removed, removed by Facebook.
I didn't even find it on YouTube.
Unclear whether they uploaded and it was removed.
It was a video essentially defending the feelings
and the actions, but saying it's time to go
home and repeating the exact same stuff that
ginned up the the anger in the first place.
Trump then also tweeted basically a defense
of the rioters as he told them to go home.
This was also removed by Twitter.
Donald Trump saying these are the things and
events that happen when a sacred landslide
election victory is so unceremoniously and
viciously stripped away from great patriots
who have been badly and unfairly treated for
so long.
He is saying this is what happens when you
steal the election from me.
It makes sense that this is what's happening.
And then he adds, Go home with love and in
peace.
Remember this day forever?
Also ultimately removed from Twitter, Trump
defending the actions of the violent riot
rioters while sort of staying, saying, go
home.
So we're going to talk about reaction to this
and the discussion of the removal of Donald
Trump.
We will, of course, cover the fact that Biden
did get the votes yesterday.
There are rumors that there will be more rioting
today and very important.
There were only as of now 52 arrests yesterday,
even though there were clearly hundreds, if
not thousands of people who trespassed, did
property damage, attacked police, broke the
law in many different ways.
The FBI has said it is a priority to identify
every single person who did that.
So I'm not going to call names out specifically
on this show.
But there are known right wing activists and
and nuts who are pictured inside the Capitol
and and committing crimes, trespassing, et
cetera.
Let's help the FBI.
There should be hundreds, if not thousands
of arrests from what happened yesterday.
And there have only been 52 as of five minutes
ago.
So let's let's actually make justice be done,
because these are folks who deserve a criminal
record.
We talk about someone holding, you know, hold
holding a tiny amount of cannabis who ends
up with a criminal record and how insane that
is.
These are folks who deserve criminal records.
OK, so let's do what we can to make that happen.